I got a run through a couple of newsy
moments with you first of all your ex
Chris soules and Victoria F what random
did you see that coming at all oh I
didn't see no one so I don't even think
Victoria and Chris saw that one coming
like I don't know how they started
talking or what happened there but yeah
random that's the only word that I keep
thinking about when I hear that story is
random I have you reached out to him
about it at all
no I'm I don't really talk to him I mean
I've done like a charity event with him
here and there but no I can't do
Victoria actually more than I talked to
Chris well talk to you to her a little
bit now I'm dating Chris I haven't dated
Chris do you does it make sense to you
as a couple no why I actually can't
really picture for I don't know Victoria
well enough but I just can't picture
Chris with anyone just because of his
lifestyle like I'm like I you know I was
obviously out of season I thought I
could live the former lifestyle but now
everything that I've been doing those
for me but I just can't you know yeah
he's still in what did the Arlington
Iowa always I've never really pictured
him in a relationship because I'm like I
he'll probably just like use arm thing
for the rest of time I don't think I'm
counting my chickens before they're
hatched but I really do believe like
my dreams on this journey I can't wait
no yes let's see if she likes the farm
life she's there she's living it now
Claire Crawley season of The
Bachelorette is next up when hopefully I
can finally get going again
Claire and Matt got in a little
back-and-forth her and Matt James over
him being on cameo and I'm wondering as
a Bachelorette how you felt about that
and what Claire had to say where would
you have lied in all that if you were in
Claire's position I have a follow-up
question is he doing that for money or
for charity he said he was doing it for
charity and I don't know if Claire knew
that when she tweeted that she also
hasn't necessarily said it was about him
but like people have drawn the lines
he's not shy about like you know that he
clearly like it's getting attention on
social media he's already living that
influencer life so I obviously back her
up because nobody ever wants to feel
like somebody's coming to meet them in
it like from up here I go the wrong
reasons I can't believe I just said that
but you never want to have that feeling
when you're looking for your partner
that's somebody you know that you could
have wind up with somebody who clearly
just wants more followers so I totally
back her up on that and I think it was
great that she stood up for herself no
matter what and who would want that you
know when they're casting and stuff you
don't know the exact person you might be
getting when you necessarily apply or
get cast right so how is a lead do you
go into it thinking we've got to be here
for me but also these people might not
have known it was me when they got in
bed with the show I know it's so true
and especially my season there's the two
bachelorettes so I feel like except to
back that some of them were not there
for me but I feel I believe in a good
love story and that it can happen and I
mean I didn't go on for a soul season
thinking like he's the love of my life I
was like man if I fell in love with him
like that'd be wild because I'm going on
this for an opportunity honest about
that I think a lot of people do but that
doesn't mean a beautiful love story
can't come out of it Maddie from Peters
season went on your podcasts on off the
vine yeah and that got a lot going Peter
and her we're kind of going back and
forth and some comments with each other
what was going through your mind as you
were watching a little more fallout
happen I felt so bad because my podcast
I like to use to give anyone a voice and
never want to drag anyone or like you
know it's it's supposed to be like an
empowering space where people feel safe
so I you know I had talked to Maddie I
talked to Hannah I had talked to Peter
and Kelly and I'm just you know wanting
to hear everyone's side of the story so
when Maddie told hers I'm like that was
really great and she seemed so sweet and
now we all know the truth okay and then
when Peter came back with his comment
saying you know she wasn't telling the
full truth there's something I was like
oh no what have I started and then I
didn't want you know Kelly Peter to be
upset with me that I was giving her this
voice that wasn't true and I just felt
so caught in the middle I'm like oh no
what am i done well it's hard right
because often the truth isn't
black-and-white is somewhere in that
gray area when I say there's three sides
to every story there is Maddie's side
there's Peter side and then there's the
truth this season we're gonna get you
know they're casting again we're gonna
get some guys who were there before what
do you think the show does that makes it
the best experience for Claire did they
just lean in and acknowledge like this
quarantine stuff happened do they
hopefully cast some newer guys some
people had critiques that the guys
weren't old enough like what what do you
think's the best case scenario for going
from older men I mean throw a couple
young in there sure but but more like
you know mature older older men and I do
think they have to lean into the
quarantine thing because I think what
we've all noticed over time especially
in this time is just being honest and
acknowledging things that are happening
is probably the best thing to do so
they're not gonna be able to travel so
you kind of got to acknowledge it it
looks like your seasons probably gonna
be on this greatest season ever oh gosh
I can't believe I forgot about that yeah
I'm scared are you yes oh my gosh
reliving that I'm is gonna be so
emotional for so many different reasons
plus being in a relationship now and
having to go back and relive all those
relationships I mean we all know the
show and where we came from and we'll
have fun with it too of course
but gosh who wants to relive
their dating history Jesus senior season
Oh
I mean he knows all about it but yes but
as he said about it about being part of
this I mean at first he was kind of like
oh boy but you know Jay said yes such a
happy-go-lucky positive person that he's
looking for the good and and he probably
won't watch I don't think I talked to
you about this but I was on Nick's
podcast this was like two times or so
ago and he told me that you told him he
signed out on the podcast it's in there
he said that you told him off camera
that you were definitely picking him I
didn't
that's hilarious I mean or if I did
maybe I was drunk but I don't know
because I remember this is so funny
because a nice I say this all the time
that people think they know what goes on
in the fantasy suites and they all just
think it's about - Wow
and it's really just a time for like
your deepest conversations and I
remember both like both guys just being
like trying to just drag the other one
and so when you're hearing things about
what one person who doesn't like the
other person has to say about that
you're like oh that's awful oh that's
terrible
no that's I wouldn't want to be with
that and then you go to the next one and
they're doing the same thing about the
other guy and I'm like oh my gosh okay
so clearly this is just you know a
jealousy thing I don't but in my mind
maybe I said that after you told me a
bunch of nasty things I don't know
[Music]